“Any changes today?”
the younger security officer, Zach, asked
as he stepped into the watchtower.
“As if,” replied his superior, a jaded,
cynical old man who insisted on being referred
to as ‘Mr Jefferson’.
“The darn thing hasn’t moved, spoken,
or done so much as stretch one of those wings
of his.”
“Another day at the office, then,” Zach
joked.
Through the window, the pair of them looked
at the towering figure a few kilometers away.
SCP-001, the Gate Guardian, stood motionless,
its fiery sword in its hand, ever protecting
its post at the precipice between our world
and paradise.
It had long been stationed at the entrance
of a dimensional gateway that led to what
was believed to be the Garden of Eden described
in the biblical Old Testament.
Much like the security officers in the Foundation
base tasked with watching the Guardian, this
was pretty much the extent of the day’s
activities.
“Hey, did you see that news about the transfer
posting?”
Zach asked, trying to stave off boredom with
as much conversation he could squeeze out
of his fellow officer.
“Yeah, I saw it,” Mr Jefferson scoffed,
rolling his eyes.
“What possesses someone like Robert Montauk
to come down here?”
“Must’ve wanted a quieter posting,”
Zach reasoned, looking out at the stillness
of the Gate Guardian.
“Won’t find one any quieter than here,”
Jefferson mused.
“Him showing up will be the most exciting
thing that’s happened here in a long while.”
Unbeknownst to both Zach and Mr Jefferson,
Doctor Robert Montauk would only be joining
the team at the Gate Guardian observation
site for a short while.
Not one of them, nor anybody else within the
Foundation, could ever guess Montauk’s true
intentions behind venturing there in the first
place: he wanted an audience with the Gate
Guardian itself.
Approaching the colossal, thousand-foot-tall
being, Doctor Montauk crossed the threshold
of the minimum safe distance from the Guardian.
Given the sheer heat of its weapon, hotter
than Earth’s sun, anything within a kilometer
of SCP-001 was at risk of being obliterated,
vaporized into atoms if they didn’t turn
back.
Which through a voice that immediately rang
out in Montauk’s ears, the Gate Guardian
commanded him to do.
“LEAVE!”
its psychic message boomed.
“Wait, wait!”
Doctor Montauk urged, holding up his hands
in what would have been a futile defense against
the Guardian’s sword.
“I know what you do when people don’t
listen to your commands, but please just give
me a minute.”
There was a silence, SCP-001 didn’t reply.
There was nobody else close enough to hear
Montauk speak to it.
So, he continued:
“You’re impossibly old.
We know that much about you.
And because of that, you must have seen things
that we can’t even begin to imagine, much
less fully comprehend.
But I’ve come a very long way to request
that you impart some information to me, if
you can.”
He paused again, as if waiting for a reply
that never came; the Gate Guardian merely
stood in the same defensive, unwavering stance.
“Tell me, please…
how much do you know about the Scarlet King?”
By this point in time, although the Foundation
was yet to realize, Doctor Robert Montauk
was slowly going insane.
His investigations into an anomalous entity
known as the Scarlet King were gradually corrupting
him, as he tried relentlessly to quantify
exactly what this entity was and how great
of a threat it posed.
Little did Montauk realize that, in trying
so hard to define and comprehend the being,
he was inadvertently fuelling its power.
The Scarlet King was an interdimensional warmonger,
an embodiment of hatred and chaos, and Doctor
Montauk was slowly falling under the King’s
influence.
Upon hearing the tiny human figure utter his
question, the immense Gate Guardian rebutted
with another single word psychic command,
one it had never been recorded giving before:
“WITNESS!”
As if his increasing instability and the creeping
influence of the Scarlet King hadn’t made
Montauk feel back enough, he instantly felt
sick.
There was a searing pain behind his eyes,
like he was staring directly at the sun, accompanied
by a nausea that made his head spin.
It took a moment of enduring the horrific
sensations before he realized what was happening:
the Guardian was trying to show him something.
Rather than give any information on the Scarlet
King verbally, SCP-001 was imparting a psychic
vision onto Montauk.
A memory of events long past?
The answers that he sought?
A warning?
Or perhaps all three.
The vision showed Montauk a time so long ago
that it couldn’t ever be forgotten, for
there was barely anyone alive to remember
it in the first place.
It was eons in the past, long before the comparatively
recent dawn of humanity.
A time only spoken of in the Dust and Blood
tablet, an artifact of the Daevite civilization;
some of the earliest worshippers of the Scarlet
King himself.
And there, marching up to the entrance of
Eden, was the crimson-clad eldritch abomination
and a horde of horrors with him.
According to the story recorded in the Dust
and Blood tablet, this would have been much
earlier in the life of the Scarlet King, perhaps
even before he assumed his now-infamous title.
Back then, he would most likely have been
known as his original name of Khahrahk, one
of multiple siblings born when the Tree of
Life was planted, and thus created all life
in the multiverse.
But, being the only one of his siblings cursed
with awareness.
Knowing the pain his existence brought him,
Khahrahk would inevitably set out on his lifelong
mission to destroy all of existence across
every dimension.
And he started by killing his siblings, consuming
them to claim their power for himself.
Around this time in pre-history, the being
that would one day be known as Scarlet King
didn’t quite possess the power that he would
several millennia later.
Although that’s not to say he was an unformidable
force of destruction, fuelled by his singular
hatred for existence.
His vow to destroy extended to the Tree of
Life that had caused him to be, along with
the tree’s Creator and all of their Creation
– in other words, everything in the multiverse,
all of creation, if you will.
So, what was the Scarlet King doing there
so long ago at the dimensional doorway protected
by the Gate Guardian?
Well, beyond the boundary between it and the
rest of the infinite multiverse, lay the supposed
Garden of Eden.
While it’s unknown if it is, in fact, the
same Eden referred to in the Book of Genesis
is up for debate, especially among the Foundation.
But a glance at it, even through the gate,
will tell you that it certainly looks like
paradise.
The space is filled with lush vegetation of
an astronomical size, populated by a number
of beings that seem to resemble the Gate Guardian
itself.
And there, protected by its watchful caretaker,
are two trees.
One is thought to be the Tree of Knowledge,
that Eve was tricked into eating an apple
from during the Book of Genesis.
The other, however, bares an unknown type
of fruit and is widely believed to be… the
Tree of Life.
Now, back in the modern age, there’s never
been a conclusive link between the Tree of
Life mentioned by the Daevites in their barbaric
civilization’s legends regarding the creation
of the Scarlet King.
But the fact that so long ago he and his most
feared generals were bearing down on the Gate
Guardian’s position, defending a garden
where there was known to be a tree of that
description…
well, it all seems rather conclusive now.
Alongside Khahrahk were six of his seven daughters,
each one of them a fearsome abomination much
like their destructive dad.
As they approached, not one needed to exchange
any words with the angelic protector of Eden;
the Gate Guardian knew what these monsters
were here for.
They would stop at nothing to pass through
his gate and uproot the Tree of Life, the
progenitor of all living beings in all existence.
Even though it was early in Khahrahk’s career
as the rampaging interdimensional warlord,
he was as steadfast as ever in his goal to
annihilate every corner of creation.
Every dimension, every parallel plane of reality,
every single pocket of existence across infinity;
they’d all come undone if he burned the
Tree of Life, pulled it out at the roots,
and splintered it until nothing remained.
To the once and future Scarlet King that the
same Tree had led to his own tortured existence,
it was the source of his suffering, and it
had to be destroyed.
The only thing standing in his way was a figure
as colossal as Khahrahk himself, wielding
a flaming sword.
“LEAVE!”
boomed the psychic voice of the Gate Guardian.
It was like a doorman standing before a group
of rowdy teenagers trying to force their way
into a movie theatre.
Except these rowdy teens were the Scarlet
King, his horrifying daughters, and the forces
he had already amassed since his creation.
The horde stood ready, waiting for the commands
of their king, who they thought would gladly
lead the charge as they marched on the Garden
of Eden to begin the destruction of existence.
But that’s not what happened.
Usually, the Scarlet King would never shy
away from a fight, preferring to lead the
charge when it came to a slaughter.
Instead, he commanded his first daughter,
A’tivik to commence the first attack on
the protector who stood in their path.
On her foul father’s word, A’tivik took
her horde and charged at the Guardian.
What she and her forces lacked in numerical
advantage, A’tivik more than made up for
in her knowledge of war, she hungered for
it, sought dominion – that was her seal,
after all.
And yet, in the face of this impending onslaught,
the Gate Guardian remained still, rooted to
the spot it had always and would always be
standing in.
A number of A’tivik’s minions burst into
flames, the very fabric of their crude forms
separated on a molecular level as they were
effortlessly rendered into nothingness.
Still, the Gate Guardian hadn’t appeared
to move an inch, had exerted no energy, despite
the damage it had done to A’tivik and her
forces in defense of Eden.
As his first daughter screeched and howled
in despair at the decimation of her horde,
her children, the Scarlet King decided he
needed to better understand his opponent.
With the wave of a clawed crimson hand, the
King commanded his next daughter, A’ghor,
to send forth her own army.
In a tidal wave of nightmarish creatures,
A’ghor sent her horrific children into battle.
She possessed a far greater quantity to do
battle on her father’s behalf; perhaps A’ghor
even believed that was the Scarlet King’s
plan.
With the greater number of her forces over
her sister’s, maybe she would be able to
overwhelm the Guardian.
But, even as her own children began to be
vaporized the closer that they got to the
gate, A’ghor had no idea she was little
more than a pawn being sacrificed so that
Khahrahk could learn more about his imposing
angelic enemy.
Another of the Scarlet King’s daughters,
a being known as A’nuht, was the next called
up to contribute to the unfolding battle.
Although, to call it a ‘battle’ undersells
just how easily the Gate Guardian seemed to
be eliminating the oncoming forces without
even moving.
While an outwardly frail seeming creature,
A’nuht’s primary strength over her sisters
was a proficiency in magic, her innate ability
to warp and reshape reality around her.
It was that power that had caused her father
to be wary of her, viewing A’nuht’s abilities
as a threat to his leadership.
And so, Khahrahk had crippled her and all
her children, leaving them unable to overthrow
him, but still loyal to their King.
Obeying her father’s command, perhaps out
of the same loyalty or fear that he would
harm her and her children further if she disobeyed,
A’nuht unfurled her magic.
She reshaped the world around them, making
it so that the passage of time moved much
slower.
And that was what revealed to the Scarlet
King his enemy’s greatest strength in combat.
The Gate Guardian had so far been able to
obliterate both A’tivik and now A’ghor’s
forces without seeming to move, but it wasn’t
by standing still.
It was moving, just much faster than the blink
of the Scarlet King’s multiple eyes.
Now that A’nuht’s magic had slowed the
passage of time, the Gate Guardian could be
seen doing battle.
As A’ghor’s atrocities spilled toward
the angel to try and overwhelm it, it effortlessly
blocked the oncoming attacks with its sword.
Everything the flaming blade connected with
instantly evaporated, bursting into atoms
as they were practically cleaved out of existence
by the Gate Guardian’s mighty weapon.
Even with time slowed to a crawl, the towering,
winged protector of Eden only appeared to
be moving at an average speed.
But when time flowed normally, without A’nuht
manipulating reality, the Guardian was simply
too fast to be observed.
Resisting the urge to dive headfirst into
the fight himself, the Scarlet King knew it
would likely lead to his untimely demise.
He refused to accept that, it could not happen,
but he still had yet to amass the strength
he would as he continued his ascent.
So, while time was slowed to a crawl and the
Gate Guardian was still engaged in combat
with A’ghor’s forces, he turned to another
of his remaining daughters: A’distat.
If the Scarlet King and his forces couldn’t
get past the Guardian, they could still try
to get to the Tree of Life while its protector’s
focus was diverted.
A’distat unleashed a wave of pestilence,
sickness, and disease spewing from her in
a cloud of vapor, heading straight towards
the angelic guardian and Eden’s entrance
beyond.
The Scarlet King knew this latest attack wouldn’t
phase or weaken the Gate Guardian; he hoped
the foul smog would instead pass through the
gateway itself into the garden.
As A’distat sent forth her power, blood
and ash soaked the landscape around them.
All the plants outside the entrance to Eden
withered and died, shriveling and decomposing
as the disgusting fog rolled towards the gate.
It washed over the Guardian, whose form only
seemed to glow brighter as he repelled the
pestilence.
It was as if it didn’t even need to think
about it, still focused on finishing off the
rest of the oncoming army.
As its glow intensified, so did the fiery
sword that the Gate Guardian swung with ease
and finesse.
Flames burst from the blade, the encroaching
fumes catching fire along with the air itself.
It ignited in a wave of fire, a defensive
inferno that repelled this latest attack.
But, for the brief few moments, while time
stayed slow, before A’nuht’s hold on reality
inevitably broke, the King had sent forth
A’tellif.
Of all his spawn, she was the most reserved,
keeping mostly to herself, never speaking.
She and her children could change their faces
and forms, shift into anything or anyone and
walk undetected through the multiverse.
And now, her father was employing her incredible
stealth abilities to slip behind enemy lines,
while the Gate Guardian was finishing off
the remaining onslaught from Khahrahk’s
other daughters.
It was as A’tellif drew near, creeping unseen
closer and closer to the entrance keeping
the Scarlet King out of Eden, that the Guardian
seemed to pause.
It slowly, ominously turned its huge head,
tilting until it was looking directly at A’tellif.
If its expression could be seen, maybe the
Gate Guardian would almost be impressed that
someone was almost able to sneak past it,
after all, it was a feat that no other being
in creation could ever hope to accomplish.
But then again, with its steadfast conviction
and dedication to its protective duty, maybe
it would have looked upon A’tellif with
anger.
With a cleaving swing of its scorching sword,
the Gate Guardian unfurled a tidal wave of
fire that engulfed everything around it.
Not just A’tellif, but A’tivik, A’ghor,
and A’distat, all the King’s daughters
that had attacked so far, along with every
one of their own children, were instantly
obliterated.
They were all reduced to empty, vacant spaces
where they had once been, their atoms separated
by a searing swing of the Guardian’s weapon.
The devastating blow by his adversary did
little to deter the Scarlet King from his
mission.
He was still set on destroying the Tree of
Life, and no loss was too great in his pursuit
of destroying existence.
He barely cared that four of his own daughters
had just been unmade by the Guardian.
A’nuht was still there, clinging on to time
as if it were a thrashing animal.
The Scarlet King could simply make her restore
her fallen sisters and their forces.
He had lost nothing, but had held back for
too long… and slowly drew his own weapon
out of thin air.
Wielding a sword that was as blood-soaked
as the Guardian’s was hot, the Scarlet King
locked blades with the one being standing
in his way.
Both the ancient angelic defender and the
attack eldritch abomination were evenly matched,
every one of their vicious strikes against
the other met with an equally strong parry.
A weapon of extreme, all-consuming heat blocked
swipes from a sharp, serrated edge that matched
the deep red that would be forever synonymous
with Khahrahk.
The force of their two swords clashing and
striking each other was so great that it rippled
out from their one-on-one fight.
The landscape around them was flattened, wiped
clean of any remaining plant life that hadn’t
already been destroyed by the forces of the
King’s daughters.
Despite having acquired nowhere near the power
he would thousands of years after this fight,
the Scarlet King was still a formidable force
in single combat.
And yet, the Gate Guardian seemed incapable
of tiring, or weakening, still standing strong
against the onslaught.
Even after wiping multiple armies out with
its flaming sword, the Guardian was still
able to hold its own against the Scarlet King,
who was furious, enraged at being so close
to the Tree of Life, yet unable to get past
his angelic adversary.
He needed to be stronger, faster, even more
ruthless than the warlord he already was.
Despite A’nuht slowing down time, the King
and the Guardian were at a stalemate…
Time.
That was it.
The Scarlet King needed more time.
Withdrawing from the fight, he realized that
this was a battle that could not be won by
sheer brute force alone.
His mission to destroy all Creation, to get
to the Tree of Life would take cunning, deception…
and more time.
If he let it, The Gate Guardian could easily
kill Khahrahk, its flaming weapon could cleave
him out of existence, and that would end the
King’s torment.
But it wouldn’t be enough, a death would
be unsatisfying knowing that the rest of existence
would go on after he was gone.
The Scarlet King couldn’t accept that, it
wasn’t enough.
So, he did the one thing nobody would expect
of him: he made a deal with the Gate Guardian.
It was an action still fuelled by his infinite
hatred for all existence, his yearning for
total chaos.
The Scarlet King knew that one day, an event
would arrive where the Guardian, and the other
beings like it in the Garden of Eden, would
spill forth and deliver judgement on this
world.
And when that Rapture happened, the Tree of
Life would be undefended.
The Scarlet King bartered with the Guardian,
that he would retreat for the time being,
so he could spend eons amassing more and more
power.
Then, when the fateful day arrived, the Gate
Guardian would allow him into Eden to destroy
the Tree of Life, while it and its brethren
were busy conducting the Rapture.
Halting their fight, the Scarlet King offered
a crimson claw to the Gate Guardian’s burning
hand…
***
Returning to reality from the intense vision,
still feeling sick at what he had witnessed,
Robert Montauk looked up at the still, silent
form of the Gate Guardian.
“Did you do it?” he yelled, desperate
to know more through his obsession with the
Scarlet King.
“Did you tell him yes?
Did you make a deal?”
There was no answer from the Guardian, just
a single word that echoed through Montauk’s
fractured mind:
“LEAVE!”
Now go and check out “SCP-001 THE SCARLET
KING – DUST AND BLOOD” and “SCP-001-
The Scarlet King - Darth Vader Begs For Mercy”
for more of the multiverse’s most monstrous
monarch!